alors autre chose qui m'a étonné vous
dites que vous êtes monté une fois sur
scène voyez vous avez joué knokke et ses
boucles y jouiez le personnage de thor
knokke
alors moi je regrette vous passé si vite
cet événement vous raconter en dépôt si
tu sais c'était un club d'étudiants à
berlin de toutes les langues et je
jouais se roule avec une grande
conviction et j'étais passionné très
amusé et je trouvais que le métier
d'acteur était prodigieux mais sait-on
j'arrive pas vous imaginez vous raymond
aron disant ça vous chatouille ou ça
vous gratouille ben je crois que vous
êtes victime comme beaucoup d'autres
d'une représentation carrie pure est
caricatural de ce que je suis enfin que
je suis autre que jure autre que celui
qui écrit dans le figaro enfin le figaro
ce ça a été une activité pendant 30 ans
et puis c'était pas toute ma vie et
d'autre part je suis moins gai quand
j'écris que dans la vie à vous êtes
qu'est la vie je suis gay dans la vie
comme si pas accablé par les malheurs je
suis gay et je suis plutôt facile pour
mes amis je crois
bon bah pas m'oublier affirmons pas vous
allez prendre très j'ai déjà écrit mais
sans penser suffit vous allez prendre